opération, on se demande comment
faire pour servir toutes ces
femmes.. dont l'afflux commence
à se faire sentir.
Notre envoyée spéciale Yasmine
Mehdi.
- Dans cette clinique
en banlieue de Détroit,
l'avalanche a déjà commencé.
On s'aurure de ne pas manquer de
matériel médical, car depuis
vendredi, les appels de partout
aux États-Unis n'arrêtent pas.
Du jour au lendemain,
M Michigan s'est transformé en
État sanctuaire.
RENEE CELIAN, propriétaire de
Northland Fami P Planning
"Mon amie au Texas a dû fermer
toutes ses cliniques, raconte
Renee Celian."
Les trois cliniques de
Northland Family Planning
procèdent à environ
9000 avortements par an.
Un chiffre qui grimpera
probablement en flèche;
du moins, c'est à ce scénario
que Renee se prépare.
"Il faudra embaucher plus de
médecins, explique-t-elle.
Tout pour éviter de fermer
la porte au nez d'une patiente
dans le besoin."
Renée ne se le pardonnerait
pas, car pour elle, le combat
est personnel.
La septuagénaire s'est faite
avortée en 1966 lorsque c'était
encore illégal au Michigan.
"On nous bandait les yeux,
on nous mettait dans une
voiture, et on nous amenait
dans un entrepôt abandonné,
"On nous bandait les yeux,
on nous mettait dans une
voiture, et on nous amenait
nsns un entrepôt abandonné,
raconte-t-elle."
Pendant sa carrière,
la docteure Lisa Harris a
accompagné des dizaines de
femmes qui se sont faites
avorter.
La gynécologue d'origine
canadienne se réjouit que
le Michigan puisse servir d'État
sanctuaire, mais avec ce statut
viendra une pression sur
le système de santé.
Il n'y pas que
les professionnels de la santé
qui essaient de s'organiser.
Ellie Young, une militante
pro-choix, ouvrira les portes de
sa maison aux femm q qui
voyageront au Michigan pour se
faire avorter.
ELLIE YOUNG, activiste pro-choix
"J'ai grandi dans une famille de
témoins de Jéhovah, il y avait
toujours des étrangers chez moi,
lance-t-elle."
Le Michigan a beau vouloir
devenir un État sancturere,
l'accès à l'avortement y est
aussi menacé. Et si l'État
devait choisir d'adopter des
lois plus restrictives, beaucoup
d'Américaines pourieient choisir
de se tourner vers le Canada, de
l'trtre côté de la rivière.
Patricia Fell est directrice
d'un théâtre féministe à
Windsor. La petite maison dans
sa cour faisait jusqu'à présent
offi d de résidence d'artiste.
L'espace sera maintenant
réservé aux Américaineququi
voudront se faire avorter au
Canada.
Renee Ciaian apprécie l'élan de
solidarité canadien, mais
elle n'y voit qu'une solution
temporaire, que très peu de
femmes pourront se permettre.
La seule option pour Renee est
de continuer à se battre dans
un pays de plus en plus
polarisé, où l'avortement divise
plus que jamais.
Sclclinique a d'ailleurs dû
resserrer ses mesures de
sécurité, rien pour décourager
la militante.
Un combat long et difficile,
mais nécessaire, croit-elle.
Pour que le Michigan reste
un État sanctuaire, une porte
ouverte pour les femmes qui
n'auront pas d'autre choix.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, au Michigan